this video was made possible by class
central.com / Pakman which lets you
watch tens of thousands of lectures from
the world's best universities check it
out by clicking the link underneath this
video this episode of the pseudo-science
mini-series brings us to UFOs
unidentified flying objects and claims
about extraterrestrial life visiting
earth the existence of extraterrestrial
life is a subject of real scientific
inquiry telescopes scan the cosmos for
evidence and radio listening devices
search the galaxy for interstellar
communications well known probability
equations like the Drake Equation
suggest that the existence of
extraterrestrial life is possible and
maybe even probable but the popular and
speculative study of reports surrounding
alien attributed UFOs is called UF ology
and it is pseudoscience ufology
investigation encompasses things like
UFO sightings alien contact and
abduction stories and supposed
government conspiracies and cover-ups of
such things and as in many
pseudo-sciences claims about UFOs and
aliens are rife with unfalsifiable
propositions questionable assumptions
and flimsy or even non-existent evidence
the first modern UFO sighting to gain
widespread news coverage was by private
pilot Kenneth Arnold in 1947 he was
flying over a national park in
Washington State and he says he saw a
number of mysterious objects miles away
from him that looked like Crescent
shapes skipping on water and in response
to Arnold's own detailed descriptions of
what he saw there have been a number of
alternative explanations offered by
experts who have closely examined the
situation including that the objects
might have been mirages or misidentified
meteors or Birds or clouds of snow
nevertheless news reports describing the
sighting gave rise to the term flying
saucer although all Arnold actually said
he had been misquoted by reporters when
they use the word saucer but this common
theme is one that we deal with a lot
with UFO claims it's often just a game
of telephone first-hand accounts are
often sensationalized and in 1949 alone
two
years after Arnold's misreported quote
flying saucer sighting the government
reported 256 UFO sightings roughly 70%
of which were described as something
reminiscent of a flying saucer private
and government inquiry into these
sightings found conclusively that many
of these UFOs were merely misidentified
high-altitude weather balloons many of
which had lights and other electronic
equipment attached to them
meteors bol IDEs and even planets Venus
is actually often mistaken for a UFO
it's the brightest object in the sky
when it's visible and it often appears
near the horizon then in the 1960s there
were a number of UFO sightings in Nevada
that were later attributed to test
flights of highly classified CIA
aircraft like the ox cart and u2 spy
planes in 2009 a spiraling light in the
skies above Norway was reported the
Russian military later explained that it
was a missile that failed to launch
which subsequently spiraled out of
control
in October of 2010 hundreds of people
reported UFOs above New York City's
shiny silvery objects in the sky turns
out somebody accidentally released 12
helium balloons at a party in
Westchester County which then drifted
over to New York City there's a long
list of UFO sightings throughout the
20th century that were debunked by
documents Declassified by the CIA in
2007 those documents are definitely
worth checking out one of the first
famous accounts of alien abduction was
by New Hampshire couple Betty and Barney
Hill in 1961 who said they had been
kidnapped by extraterrestrials from the
Zeta Reticuli system Barney Hill
revealed details about the aliens who
supposedly abducted him and his wife and
historians have noted that Hills
descriptions of the aliens and the
entire situation actually were
strikingly similar to an episode of the
TV show Outer Limits which had aired
just two weeks before Hill gave the
account in 1964 he'll describe the
aliens behavior their physical
appearance and their clothing all of
which matched the Outer Limits episode
that recently aired Betty Hills account
of the incident also was curious
similar to other previous alien fiction
before they were abducted Betty read
Donald Kehoe's book the flying saucer
conspiracy which depicts four dwarf like
creatures appearing out of a hovering
object and eventually dragging two
people into their ship to examine them
this story closely resembles Betty Hills
account of what happened we also know
that before the supposed abduction Betty
Hill was already abnormally interested
in UFOs like I said she read the Flying
Saucer conspiracy before the supposed
abduction and she even wrote letters to
the author
Betty Hills sister also claims to have
seen a UFO years before Betty and
Barney's incident many people who have
reported alien abduction have later been
determined to have actually been
experiencing what's known as sleep
paralysis which is a real medical
phenomenon it can include hallucinations
of flashing lights buzzing sounds
experiences of floating even impressions
of
other people being in the room and a
2002 Harvard study entitled memory
distortion in people reporting abduction
by aliens found that people who claimed
abductions are also prone to what's
called false memory syndrome when given
memory tests alien abductees regularly
claim to recall words items and
sentences that they hadn't actually seen
false memories and sleep paralysis
definitely seem like more convincing
explanations for accounts like these as
opposed to actual alien abduction by
extraterrestrials but most importantly
abduction claims have no concrete
evidence and have relied only on the
accounts of those involved and nothing
else many UFO lodges claim that the US
government is involved in cover-ups of
UFO and alien abduction incidents
according to declassified memos when UFO
sightings became more widespread after
World War two
the CIA did conceal its investigation of
these sightings from public view for
fear of inflaming quote alarmist
tendencies but this is very different
from covering up the existence of actual
aliens area 51 a highly secretive Air
Force Base in Nevada has been the
subject of a lot of speculation by UF
ologists but
area 51 secrecy isn't proof of anything
tight security at area 51 and other
similar military installations make
sense given that highly classified
aircraft are developed and tested at
these sites one of the most
sensationalized events in UFO folklore
is the famous Roswell incident when in
July of 1947 just outside Roswell New
Mexico an unidentified object crashed to
the ground inside a sheep pasture one of
the men who found the crashed object
described that it was made partly of a
strange indestructible metallic foil
material he had never seen or heard of
before an Air Force Base recovered the
wreckage and a Roswell newspaper ran a
story claiming that a flying saucer had
crashed the next day an air force
official stated it was actually just a
conventional weather balloon but
photographs of the wreckage made it
clear that the object was far too large
and technologically equipped to be a
weather balloon and for decades UF
ologist developed complex conspiracy
theories about the object in Roswell
being of extraterrestrial origin and the
government's efforts to cover it up
several pieces of footage surfaced that
showed autopsies performed on the aliens
found at the crash but the filmmakers
later admitted that they were just
hoaxes in 1994 and 1997 the US military
released two reports revealing that the
crashed object was one of many highly
classified nuclear surveillance balloons
deside designed to monitor nuclear
testing by the Soviet Union which would
very reasonably explain why the
government would want to keep them
secret the CIA and Air Force have long
investigated the legitimacy of UFO
reports with various teams of scientists
and military experts last major
government investigation was called
Project Blue Book which took place from
1952 to 1970 the summary of the findings
were clear stating quote there is no
evidence submitted to or discovered by
the Air Force that sightings categorized
as unidentified represent technological
developments or principles beyond the
range of modern scientific
and there was no evidence indicating
that sightings categorized as
unidentified were extraterrestrial
vehicles it's possible and maybe even
mathematically probable that intelligent
life exists somewhere elsewhere in the
universe
however conclusions that aliens have
visited our planet only to be observed
as UFOs or have abducted humans and that
it has all been covered up by government
conspiracy lack actual evidence the
evidence that UFO gist offer is mostly
limited to people's memories alone or
sometimes includes grainy Loch Ness
monster esque photographs Occam's razor
tells us that the simplest solution to a
problem is preferable to a more complex
one if it explains the circumstances
equally well there are a large range of
possible explanations for UFO sightings
and suppose it abductions the least
obvious answer to any of them is aliens
the burden of proof is on the UF
ologists and so far what they've
provided just doesn't hold up but a
great way to find out more about the
real scientific quest for knowledge
about the cosmos and the existence of
aliens is to head over to class
central.com slash Pakman they have an
excellent new course from the University
of Edinburgh called astrobiology and the
search for extraterrestrial life class
central offers tens of thousands of
University courses on almost any topic
you can imagine click the link in the
description to start searching for
top-rated College lectures from
world-renowned universities they've got
everything politics economics business
science math computer programming you'll
definitely find something you'll love
check out the courses many of which are
totally free at class central.com slash
Pakman or just click the link underneath
this video